comme vous le voyez c'est vraiment un
très bel endroit et la maison a des
fondations solides
[Musique]
vous voulez bien m'excuser qu'est-ce qui
t'es arrivé un gars que les trop vite je
refous plus les pieds dans supermarché
[Musique]
encore là mais ça peut plus continuer
tu es au courant en nous je suis
détective privé maintenant
il va falloir que tu trouves un taf oh
je rêve d'une table non j'ai dit un taf
c'est maintenant ou jamais tu es un vrai
Phénix ma belle je sais
est-ce que je peux savoir qui vous êtes
une vraie détective ça se voit pas j'ai
besoin de personne faut croire que j'ai
ça dans le sang vous avez besoin de moi
et moi j'ai besoin de ce boulot je vous
attends lundi matin à 9h t'apporte je me
lève jamais avant 11h je suis sur le
poids de me faire un paquet d'oseille je
travaillais la presse en parlera bientôt
une enquête de détective de détective
pas la peine de mettre des guillemets
j'ai l'impression que c'est encore une
de tes idées farfelues que tu as entre
deux cures on finit toujours par
rebondir mais je sens qu'il me manque un
truc pour aller de l'avant
on s'attendait pas à ce que les choses
changent aussi vite
pourtant elle change
j'ai pas envie d'être obligé de revenir
ici pour enterrer ma soeur ça va péter
attention
tu arrives à un point de non-retour
cette histoire prend de l'enversure ça
peut être nos ticket pour la cour des
grands
[Musique]